DAVID HODGE: So what are we
going to be talking about
today is whether or
not numbers exist.
We're going to be thinking about
three different schools
of thought on this.
First one's Platonism, second
one's nominalism, and the last
one is fictionalism.
So mathematical Platonism takes
its lead from Plato,
obviously, as the
name suggests.
And the idea is that
numbers exist.
They really are things.
They're objects.
But they're abstract objects,
so they don't exist in the
same way that tables
and chairs do in
space and in time.
Numbers exist outside
space, outside time.
They don't cause other
things to happen.
They're totally abstract
objects.
One of the reasons that people
like mathematical Platonism is
that we think that a lot of
claims about numbers in
mathematics are true.
Right, so certainly I think
that things that
mathematicians say are true.
I think that's a good
starting point.
But they say things like
there's a number
between 6 and 8.
That seems like it's a true
thing, it's the number 7.
And Platonists think that that
means that there must exist an
object that is the number 7,
even if it's not an object
that you can touch.
And they appeal to kind of
similar reasoning about the
way that we speak about
the ordinary,
kind of concrete world.
So if I say to you that there's
a nose between two
eyes, that nose had better exist
for what I say to be
true, right?
If there's no nose here, then
what I've said is false.
So in the same kind of way,
right, if there's a number
between six and eight, that
thing had better exist.
Platonists aren't happy to use a
loose sense of "exist" here,
so they think that exists
just means exists.
And so in the same way that a
table exists, a chair exists,
a number exists.
All the numbers exist,
in fact.
It just so happens that
they're not located
in space and time.
So it's a difference about
location, rather than whether
or not they exist, or whether
they exist in a
different kind of way.
All sorts of fun problems
with the view.
The first of which that you come
across, particularly when
you start teaching this stuff,
is that's crazy.
So numbers exist outside
space and time?
What does that even
mean, right?
It's really, really hard to kind
of get your head around.
But we can be a bit more refined
than that when we're
objecting to mathematical
Platonism.
So one of the things that we
said was that mathematical
claims are true, but that
mathematical claims are
actually claims about these
abstract objects.
These abstract objects don't
causally interact with us
because they're abstract.
OK, but we think that
mathematicians
are massively reliable.
So what they say, pretty much
guaranteed to be true.
If their claims are actually
about these abstract objects,
then it looks like we need some
explanation of how those
mathematicians so reliably
track that
world of abstract objects.
So if a mathematician tells you
that 6 times 7 is 42, then
what he's saying is true.
What they're saying is true.
How is it that they're so
reliably managing to access
this world of abstract
objects?
Answering that question's
really hard for the
Platonists, because they just
don't think we can interact
with that world.
Our second theory is
mathematical nominalism.
So what the nominalist
wants to do is
agree with the Platonist.
That all of our mathematical
claims are true, but that our
mathematical claims should best
be understood as claims
about objects in the world.
So tables, chairs, pencils,
those kinds of things.
And to get a kind of bit of
intuition on this kind of
thing, often helps to think
about the way you might teach
a child to count.
So children don't tend to be
born with these kind of
abstract principles.
One, two, three, four,
five, six, and so on.
What we tend to do is to say,
like, here's a pencil.
Here's another.
Now you've got two pencils.
And it seems that what we do
when we learn to count is we
count with respect to a
particular type of objects, or
to objects in general.
And what the nominalist says is,
well, that's all there is
to number talk, right?
What you mean when you say 6
times 7 is 42 is that if you
had 6 lots of 7 objects,
you'd have 42 objects.
That's what mathematics
is about.
It's about concrete things
in the world.
This kind of nominalist view
begins to run into trouble
when we start to think about
more complicated numbers or
numerical concepts.
So if we start to think about
the square root of minus 1,
for instance, and the imaginary
numbers and so on.
So it's really easy to say 2
plus 2 equals 4 is about these
2 objects and those 2 objects,
and there being 4 objects.
Much harder to see what object
or thing might be the square
root of minus 1.
So if you're a mathematical
Platonist, it's really easy.
It's just another number,
just like all the rest.
But if you're a nominalist,
what's the
thing that it's about?
Looks really, really hard to see
what that's going to be.
So pi is also similarly
complex, right?
So if you're a nominalist, it
looks like you're going to
think that numerical
talk is just talk
about concrete things.
But of course, pi doesn't seem
to have a precise value, or at
least we certainly can't
calculate that value.
So there's a real question
for the nominalist here.
How are you going to understand
pi as a thing, or a
collection of things, when
we can't ever get to that
terminating value?
Our third group in the
philosophy of mathematics is
the mathematical fictionalist.
So I said at the start that I
think it's a good thing to say
that what mathematicians
say is true.
And the fictionalist doesn't
quite agree.
So the fictionalist says,
actually, mathematical
discourse is false.
It's really useful, really
helpful, but it's
systematically just false.
That's quite an extreme view to
take, given the success of
science within which mathematics
is embedded, but
that's the view that
the mathematical
fictionalist takes.
So the fictionalist says numbers
don't exist, whereas
the Platonist says numbers are
these existing abstract
objects, and the nominalist says
mathematical discourse is
about concrete objects
in the world.
The fictionalist says it's
not about anything.
It's just a useful story that
we've developed to help
ourselves get on in the world.
BRADY HARAN: But surely the
mathematical fictionalist uses
modern communications, is
dependent on satellites.
How do they explain
those things?
Because obviously they
use numbers.
How do they explain that they're
using something that
they say doesn't exist?
DAVID HODGE: So what the
fictionalist has got to do is
try and explain away the success
of mathematics and the
success of science.
But without saying that
mathematical claims are true.
And one strategy that the
fictionalist can deploy around
here is to say that success in
the world isn't a hallmark of
truth, or needn't be a
hallmark of truth.
We were talking about modern
communications, technology
relying on all of this
mathematics.
What the fictionalist will say
is what that indicates is that
the mathematics is successful.
It doesn't indicate
that it's true.
If it was true, says the
fictionalist, these
mathematical objects, these
platonic objects that the
mathematical Platonist thinks
exist, those things
would have to exist.
But they don't.
And so in fact, our
mathematical
discourse can't be true.
It can at best be a
useful fiction.
There are appeals that they can
make around here that kind
of help bring out the sort
of thing that they
might want to do.
Imagine that you thought that
the Bible was a work of
fiction, for instance.
Some people do, some
people don't.
But you might think it codifies
a really useful set
of moral principles.
And you might think that there's
no such thing as truth
and morality.
But you might think as guiding
principles go, these are
pretty helpful.
They help us get on
in the world.
Don't kill other people.
Help societies develop, which
helps us develop in
interesting kinds of ways.
The mathematical fictionalist
might say very similar things
about the language
of mathematics.
Helps us get on, but that it
helps us to get on doesn't
mean that it's true.
BRADY HARAN: Where do you
stand on all this?
You've very neutrally given
me the three positions.
Is there one that resonates
with you?
DAVID HODGE: So the view that
resonates with me the most, I
guess, is mathematical
nominalism.
So I don't think that there
are abstract objects.
I don't think that there
are numbers.
I think that it's too much of
a stretch to think that
mathematics is false.
My colleagues in the math
department will, I'm sure, be
delighted by this.
So I adopt the middle ground,
what I take to be the middle
ground, anyway, which is
a kind of mathematical
nominalism.
BRADY HARAN: You were telling
me that the nominalist runs
into problems with some of
these more spectacular
irrational numbers.
Do you run into problem
with those numbers?
DAVID HODGE: Yes, that means
that I inherit all of the
problems that the mathematical
nominalist faces.
The kind of move that I like
to make around here with
respect to pi is to say that
whenever we actually calculate
with it, when we're using it
mechanically, if you like,
what we're doing is we're using
a best approximation.
Now, that's a spectacularly
accurate, well, it's a
spectacularly long
approximation, anyway.
I really shouldn't say it's
accurate, because I don't
think it maps to a
platonic ideal.
But it's a spectacularly long
and very useful approximation.
But I don't think there's
anything other than that
endless sequence, I guess.
And of course, you can derive
that perfectly acceptably.
I think the reason that
philosophers get into the
philosophy of mathematics, one
of the reasons, anyway, is
precisely because there
are so many things to
philosophize about.
It's another thing for us
to get excited about and
interested in.
The grand tradition of thinking
about numbers, it
goes right back to
Plato, hence the
mathematical Platonism.
And so people just get excited
and interested in it, I think.